<h3>Overview of the Khan Academy Library</h3>
There's now a lot of content on the Khan Academy
so I thought I'd give your a quick overview video of how to think about the playlists
so the most basic playlist is the arithmetic playlist
arithmetic
and this is
it literally starts at one plus one equals two
and it moves
about as far as operations on decimals long division
things like that
the next most advanced playlist
is pre-algebra
if you're starting from scratch you might want to go in this order
pre-algebra
and pre-algebra as the name implies covers
a lot of the foundational concepts for algebra
like adding, subtracting, multiplying, dividing negative numbers and fractions and exponents
and then we have several playlists that address
actual algebra so there's
an algebra playlist
there is an algebra playlist
there it is an algebra one playlist
algebra one playlist
and then there is a
there is a California
California standards
California standards and there's two playlists
California standards algebra one
and California standards algebra two
this just algebra playlist this is the the I would
call this kind of the main
playlists covering algebra
when I just make an arbitrary algebra video I put it in this playlist
and I try to put it in order of
of of of of I guess advancement or of difficulty
this starts at the most basic algebraic equations
but with one caveat that
the the first few videos in this playlist are old
videos these are some of the very first videos
that I did when I started making  YouTube videos
and so they're not in HD, they're kind of
rough I'm using Microsoft  paint
they're they're not the the smoothest
videos on the planet
but then obviously it also has a lot of new videos in this
and this algebra playlist covers both algebra one and algebra two
and I merged it into one playlist because frankly algebra two
has a lot of overlap or a lot of review with algebra one
this algebra one playerlist
this is worked examples from ck12.org's
ck12.org's open source algebra one book which
is a fairly comprehensive for covering the
California standards and for those of you
who aren't in California what I say is
this is fairly comprehensive for algebra one and if you know algebra one by these standards
you're probably going to know the great majority
of what you need to know
wherever you might be taking algebra
and frankly if you watch both of these playlists
I'm pretty sure you're going to be able to
do any type of algebra problem that you might
see in any curriculum
math is math
now this is worked examples that you can and
it's all done recently so all of these videos
are of of fairly good quality
and they're all in high definition
and you could just watch this algebra one
playlist in order
and i'll just give you a little bit of warning
the first sixteen videos
sixteen videos
the very first ones are kind of an overview
so they move a little bit faster so if you
have a little bit
if his you're seeing algebra for the first time
and they seem like they're moving a little quickly
that's just because they're giving a survey of
the course
and that's why..
and I did that just because that's the order that they were displayed in the book
but after those first sixteen video
starting with one step equation
it actually goes at a very moderate pace
and I do a lot of examples
and explain the concepts as I do the examples
so if you're just starting out want to learn
algebra
what I'd recommend reviewing pre algebra, never hurts
then these are the two core algebra playlists
and you could start at either one
and find where you
where you feel comfortable
I would recommend
if you're some place in between you know a little
bit of algebra, start at the beginning
watch every video and both of these playlists
and if there's something just
super duper easy to you then you move on to
the next video
but just make sure that you have all of your bases covered
now, these these videos right these playlists right
here the California standards
these are just worked examples
based on the California standards
so after watching these you want to see more examples
it'll never hurt to watch these two playlists right there
now once you're done with algebra
you might want to look at the geometry playlist
you could probably start on the geometry playlist just with
pre-algebra but it's good to have that algebraic foundation there
and in most school systems
you take algebra one first
then geometry
then algebra two
so this is just a recommended path you might want to
take
and then after geometry
you're ready to move into trigonometry
trigonometry
and after algebra you are also ready to move
'cos this playlist as I said it
goes through algebra two
after this you're also ready for pre-calculus
you're also ready for pre-calculus
and I'll write it at the same level as trigonometry because
in most
school systems you take trigonometry and pre-calculus
in the same year
usually your junior or your senior year
and then obviously after  pre-calculus
and trigonometry
the next
you now are ready for calculus
and this is a fairly extensive playlist
it covers
calculus one, two and three
so differential integral and multi-variable and vector calculus
so in some places even you could almost say
even through calculus four
now we have another
another playlist that has the word algebra in it
but it is a much more advanced algebra
even though it might sound like a simpler algebra
it's called linear algebra
linear algebra
and if you've never seen algebra before
do not watch this playlist it might sound
like "hey linear algebra is easier than non-linear algebra"
No, this is a mathematically rigorous course
that normally math and engineering majors take
in their, probably their sophomore year of college
and I would say that
you could start off if you have just a basic
understanding of pre-calculus you could probably
you could probably start the linear algebra
playlist
but I would recommend being fairly sophisticated mathematically
you probably want a little bit of your calculus out of the way, to start it
even though it is really algebra
it is mathematically more sophisticated than a lot of what goes on
in the calculus playlist
and in the calculus playlist once you're about halfway
through
you don't have to go through the whole playlist
you're then ready for another advanced playlist that we have
and that's differential equations
differential equations
probably two-thirds of the way
through the calculus playlist you're probably
then ready for differential equations
another usually sophomore level course
for math and science and engineering majors
now everything else we have some
we have some probability and statistics
algebra is all you really need for that,
but I'll put it here because it's reasonably advanced
probability
there's a probability playlist
and then there is a statistics playlist
they're obviously related
you might want to do the probability one first
but you don't have to
there's probability and there is a statistics
statistics playlist
we also have
a California standards geometry playlist
and that's worked examples just like that
one over there
so i'll do that like that we also have
California
standards
California standards geometry
so you can
you can look at that if you want to see more geometric
worked examples
and then when you think about the sciences
we have physics
and the physics this is mainly I call them
applied algebra problems
so you might want to watch
physics right around after you finish algebra
there's only a few videos that require calculus
I'll eventually make an entire playlist
on calculus based physics
most of this it's just algebra based physics
so you're ready to go if you have a good solid understanding of algebra
and then the other sciences and the chemistry
uh it'd be nice to have algebra out of the way, pre algebra is probably enough for most of it
pre algebra is probably enough for most of it but
algebra
if you have your algebra out of the way
then you're going to have no trouble at all with
the chemistry playlist
chemistry
and then biology does deal with a little bit of
of probability
and things like that so it wouldn't hurt
but that's actually that doesn't even require
too much mathematics or at least the mathematics
that I've diagrammed here.
we could put biology here
I guess the big take away is that
algebra's really important for
pretty much anything you want to do.
there's some genetics problems that require
some basic level and
and some population genetics of population
genetics problems that have some biology in it and then
all the finance and economics that also
I think it assumes
a base level of algebraic understandings
so the things on banking
things on banking you don't have to have the
super advanced if you just go maybe
a halfway through one of these playlists you are
probably ready for these
banking economics
economics
and finance
so hopefully that gives you a good overview of everything
that's
on the Khan Academy
and let me know if you have any questions